hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to people
as you all know I am very rarely wrong
but in my last video the top 11
nostalgic myfox I accidentally gave
credit to the wrong person who made
those surreal background videos that
gave you all nightmares now I am NOT one
to deny credit to a person who scares
the abstract shit out of you
so here's the address of the real artist
who did those videos you can find all
sorts of animations illustrations and
fucked up 2d Bell be sure to question
your perception of reality watch them at
your own risk
not with that out of the way let's talk
about disaster movies no no no not that
kind of disaster movie I'm a natural
disaster movies for some reason in the
mid-90s we became really tired of
supernatural villains trying to kill us
so we decided why don't we let the hand
of God piss us off with every natural
horror that you could imagine
volcanoes shipwrecks floods you name it
well we did and what was one of the
highest-grossing unnatural disaster
films to ever come out their genre none
other than the swirling Men is simply
known as twister no no that game is kind
of hot I'm talking about the movie
totally devoid of hotness mostly devoid
of hotness the Jean de bon epic failure
twister
a film that asks many daring questions
like how many bill Paxton's does it take
to slug your head against a wall when
did the special effects of tornadoes
take over the special effects of
storytelling and is that Daniel from
lost well let's not keep this whirlwind
of answers away from us any longer let's
take a look so it starts off with oddly
enough a twister
oh god that makes the movies almost over
right we see a family hive in their
shelter trying to avoid the monstrous
beast that approaches them
no no don't do that you're mocking
Dorothy and Toto outside
we see the father trying to keep the
door shut but just can't compete with
the life that you would more likely find
on a restroom door as opposed to the
door that's used to protect your family
talk about a lane way to save a buck at
the general store and you cheap you just
love you bet love the mother and
daughter of course survived the tornado
despite having the door open so it
really would have been better the father
just stood there and did nothing if
you're too stupid to realize that your
two-for-one sale locks will give out you
be leaving your wife and daughter
husband and father was you just might be
a poorly written character well enough
of that emotional drama as we suddenly
cut to several years later we're from
the sound of it the opening of Oklahoma
is about to begin
we see our main character bill paxton
who's playing a character named bill
yeah that's a quest wretch he's off to
meet up with his current wife Joe to
have assigned some divorce papers so
that he can marry his new fiancee a
psychiatrist named Melissa and if you
think she has any problems with Bill
seeing his former wife again you had to
be mistaken why because he invited her
along with him oh yeah that's not like a
romantic weekend doesn't it hey honey
you want to drive 12 hours across the
boring fields that you can meet up with
my current wife who doesn't want to
divorce me at all
what grande girl happened so it turns
out bill and Joe used to chase tornadoes
together as were introduced to their
team of crack scientists including
Cameron from Ferris Bueller's Day Off a
chick who I swear is thelma's sister
from scooby-doo an Academy Award winner
Philip Seymour Hoffman as dusty showing
us they truly knows how to earn that
Oscar gold 300 manly handshake ensues hi
I'll be playing your quirky character
actor for the next 20 films I'm in dusty
one to explain to Melissa why you are
the way you are be careful he bites so
everyone thinks bill has returned Jill
is gonna wig when she sees he's bug I'm
not back hey welcome back huh not like
he's really just there to meet up with
Joe
this shouldn't be uncomfortable at all
should it hi Joe
heyyo I'm happy fattest okay how long
until these two get back together I mean
you can literally tell in the first
sentence that they're going to reconcile
so how many more of these forts I'm not
into you Singh's do we have to put up
with okay I'm just gonna get this over
with
oh you want the papers see him you need
him right this second Oh it'd be nice
yes what's the urgent urgency act like
you're getting married ma'am my god so
many levels on paper the awkward levels
are through the roof zip Belinda
Melissa narrow Melinda in there
somewhere
oh there's only been Melissa sighs all
right how much for browsing I guess
all right this is painful let's see how
things are going with dusty Melissa the
suck zone and second five go back to the
awkward couple oh hello
nice to meet you you'll just told me the
happy news which US marriage hmm you
taking the vows and sweet oh good
dusty prose we just wanted to get it
done before Billy started as new job
that's right that's right weatherman
what what ahead I said weatherman I
think it's great yeah the tone there was
no tone if you have a problem being a
weatherman I don't have a problem being
a weatherman because this is what I want
to see in a tornado movie couples
arguing it's like the lifetime in
disaster bills you chuck that's right
boy good job the truck new life it's
like a whole new you I'm sorry I still
think out my character for man about two
you allow me to fix it never wasn't
expecting on coming out here at all you
said you'd meet me at Dorothy Dorothy
what about her she's here she'll me well
I hope you went after what you did to
her
no Dorothy turns out is a machine
designed to go inside a tornado and
release sensors to study its movement
scientists have been studying tornadoes
forever but still nobody knows how a
tornado works we have to get inside his
head studies psyche how'd he get it in
the tornado
this is sucks up all right keep the
camera off a dusty way it's hard enough
watching the main character but faster
than you can say blow me the beginnings
of a tornado are spotted and the team
must rush to get Dorothy inside for
getting again about those pesky divorce
papers the more I say the more confers
might not being back nests but all is
not well in tornado land as the team is
accompanied by some unwelcomed old
friends
Sheila's very name in lights douche it
turns out Jonas is there evil
competition driving in all Latin you so
why do they hate each other so much we
all start out in the same lab and Jonas
went out and got himself some corporate
sponsors back son of a batch he's got a
lot of high-tech gadgets
he's got no instincts
is that it for the mining that's science
not like us we like being financially
bankrupt with no money to support our
research it gives us an edge but as it
turns out Jonas played by Cary Elwes has
his own version of Dorothy as well which
makes Paxton mad about this hell you
talking about Dorothy oh I get it you
want to take credit for my design you
like that I'm doing American and a
southern accent so he came and tell that
I'm British it was our idea and you know
it
unrealized I did unreal I Gigi I never
do tornado hunting with such a
competitive sport look at his
performance there are flies that eat
shit that don't spawn does make shit
eating grin as he does so stick around
because a day is a sniffing the dirt or
over and remember to eat plenty of
Welch's grape gin one of the sponsors on
this little expedition down the
squeezable bottle oh and by the way I
really enjoy your weather reports that's
time
I'll teach you to make fun of television
meteorology okay so bill agrees to stick
around to help Dorothy fly because Laura
knows he can't let Jonas into it first
okay it's okay everything's fine are you
sure yeah yeah everything's okay
yeah we're just hanging out with the
woman I'm still technically married to
for a day without your permission
increasing the possibilities that will
ultimately get back together in front of
your eyes is that cool so we see bill
try to get in tune with the wind and the
clouds trying to be one with the store
gee it's almost as if bill can read the
storms mind like he can tell what the
storm is thinking but that would be
absolutely retarded wouldn't it so
you're telling me that Billy knows what
a storm is thinking that's my knife that
come that's right he can tell what the
storm is thinking he can also read the
minds of tree Chipmunks and garbage cans
go
finally a twister spotted as the team
rushes to the cars to try and hunt it
down
so Bill's gonna ride with his wife right
listen follow us in the truck to stay
behind Dusty's van you'll be safe back
there I gotta go with job no it turns
out this mission is too important to
ride with your fake loved ones in this
situation it's better to ride with your
loved ones in denial I don't know how to
leave him while we're driving towards
the twister we're fortunate enough to
listen to some of the noises Greatest
Hits
yeah and how is this release
no no no I don't need any useful help
from you okay that's just scary
my song
this Souls much to handle no this is
crazy this is bad business isn't the
least bit delightful
there any gentrified anywhere
haha
all right
last night
thank God a monstrous disaster arrives
to lighten the mood as Jonas isn't far
behind the stormchasers tracks dr.
Miller yes I think the turn left here
miles do it you got it
what did it suck about choir so now that
we finally spotted one of God's most
awesome feats of nature what are we
gonna do argue of course she's a
therapist yours Christ what you could
resist a new drama therapy what I'm tiny
therapy say that I need a therapist
what did I possibly need a therapist for
you're the gun
I just learned if we're gonna chase this
tornado or if you just want to catch the
next one
shit no wait I want to see who's gonna
win that argument bouncer is on the
ground oh do we have to see that
onslaught of wind and destruction I was
hoping they're going to talk about the
financial situations next
is it me or did the tornado just roar
well I got some dinosaurs in that Bart
house or something
so they hide under a bridge which is
actually the stupidest thing you can do
considering not only can it collapse on
you but it's also a wind tunnel suction
as Joe becomes fascinated by the
mysterious wonder I'm so intrigued by
the way it spins so the tornado leads
them but takes the truck somehow as it
quickly disappears into the atmosphere
where's my truck awesome yeah cuz that's
what hysterical one wants to see Philip
Seymour Hoffman right up in your face
and who's following close behind look at
that that's right body don't even help
them out
that's what corporate sponsors do to get
kids yeah that's right kiss someone for
me dusty wait so they decide to pick up
their feet and try again that's another
tornado is on the move
following right behind the Jackass
brigade
their spirit yes but you also have to
admire hip teas if my fans because every
tornado hunter should keep them food
cleaner fresher better
I am blooming but bill senses a
disturbance in the force look at the
updraft the angle it's gonna ship this
track are you sure oh yes definitely a
sidewinder so like they said we don't
know anything about how a tornado works
except exactly where it's going to go
you don't need science just ask dances
with funnel clouds over there it's
moving away looks like they're gonna
entertain damn it Tony I thought you'd
come this thing was gonna stay on the
same heading well that's what you get
when you're in it for the money sir so
they come across a pair of tornadoes
over a bridge where they can actually
see cow is flying right past them we got
cows it's okay they're taking me to
McDonald's anyway so the tornado passes
over our heroes and once again it
suddenly disappears have you noticed how
they just immediately vanish after every
encounter what does bill paxton taste
bad or something ha sadly though Bill's
wife is not the least bit enthralled no
one
you used to tell me that you chase
tornadoes deep Donna I wish that was a
metaphor there are no metaphors honey
the movie's not clever enough for them
so Dustin the teen inform Jo that they
need to take a break and get something
to eat
use your adult words so they drop by
Joe's aunt where she cooks up some steak
and eggs for the entire group there they
get a nasty little encounter on the TV
screen they are very very unpredictable
as some of my more fortunate colleagues
found out earlier on today
tournament uh we hope to change all that
with a system that I have devised right
after I'm done watching Kung Fu Panda on
blu-ray and DVD available on most
Walmart stores while there we also hear
about the different levels that
tornadoes are classified as such as f1
f2 and so forth was that enough free
solid f2 a little uh encounter me out
back there's a strong f2 after you maybe
that receive some that force yeah you
know tornadoes don't sound as
threatening when you name them after
buttons on your keyboard
is there an f5 we don't mention it fives
in this house little lady what would
that be like finger if got yeah middle
finger maybe
you see f3 would be like the nose hairs
of God at 4 you might be lucky to get
the toenail at 5
bet the whole lucky none of you have
ever seen that for just one of us ah
that poor lost soul that bill paxton
isn't the least bit in love with she was
the girl in the beginning of the movie
who lost her father to the twister and
as we see in the next tornado hunt they
go on she's obsessed with hunting every
last one down why does you think her
father's gonna show up in one of them
stay with that house and come after you
yes apparently a factually bound
scientist is convinced that tornadoes
are in fact serial killers and even
though they're nowhere near the CB radio
Melissa hears every single word they're
saying
Joe things go wrong you can't explain it
you can't predict it stop living in the
past and look at what you got right in
front of you what do you say me Joe
don't still not walk with you though gee
I'm start to think that this asshole who
tossed me aside on several occasions
ignores me every chance he gets actually
has food for huh joy meanwhile at a
drive-in where they're showing much
better scary movies Melissa starts
thinking that maybe being married to
someone who's still married to another
person by every meaning of the
definition isn't such a good thing but
she doesn't have long to think about it
as guess what the hell shows up no it
can't be
are you really serious
how many tornadoes can there be in one
day is this like the eleventh belated
plague of Egypt I mean this simply does
not happen it's already here
of course it's already here just assume
it's always in the coffee shop waiting
for you and just to make the monster
ization of this twister complete they're
nice enough to put the face of Jack
Nicholson over the cloud isn't that
something here's twisty once again the
tornado vanishes after passing over them
but the tornado busters seem to have a
good idea about where it'll appear again
the extremely thing it looks to hit what
Kira head-on not leading back home oh
wait go it's too dangerous so they rush
to Hans house as they look over all the
destruction of left behind Jo I guess
sees a ghostly image of her family which
is kind of strange cuz she's in it too
avenge my twister Eid al as they get to
her house and managed to pull her out
before the place collapses they say it's
because the building gave away but I
don't know I think it's because dusty
stepped on it here Melissa finally
decides to talk to Bill and dump the
idiotic bastard I'm saying goodbye yeah
you know what I can't get paint with
this funny thing is I'm not that upset I
can't imagine why that is what about you
oh don't worry about me as long as I'm
far away from dusty I'll be okay but it
looks like the final battle is just
ahead of them as dusty reports on big
surprise another tornado in the area I
don't even know if you want to know but
I think it's happening NSSL predicted an
f5 all right twister
it is a bee-utiful day bar fight crowds
are hype the fighters are ready and
we're excited to see the most impossible
unpractical of ridiculous climaxes it's
a beautiful day Bar intelligence to be
insulting God he's such but before they
can get there someone else is beating
them to the punch but bill tries to warn
them that they're too close to the
tornado and then it's gonna turn around
and hit him so just listen to me this is
not yet on this frequency because I'm
telling you happy I know you can hear me
turn around now maybe we should do what
he says he'd never put us in our weight
when I want your opinion I'll give it to
you I don't need your pity I'll need a
man's opinion
I'm Jonas P opinion hate ha but it may
turn out that wasn't such a hot idea
remember to drink Pepsi well they could
still be okay probably not but the
twister quickly starts coming after our
heroes as it throws everything in their
path
everything you can imagine is thrown at
them wheels debris tractors even a
friggin house yeah what else could they
possibly throw on their way
look out it's the Sears Tower the
Titanic Ozzy Osbourne
whoo whoo there's a tornado finally the
to get Dorothy in the twister release
all the sensors
Wow and what do the sensors tell us that
tornadoes are unpredictable
fuck but the f5 isn't through as it
continues to actually follow our heroes
everywhere they go what do they have
some tornado treats in their pockets
this is a bug hug get over back over
pores so how do they eventually outsmart
the twister by strapping themselves to a
pipe with a leather belt
these pipes go to at least three feet we
anchor to we might have a chance of
course here I thought the smart thing to
do was hide in a shelter our basement
but no if you got a belt in a set of
pipes strap yourself to helmet you won't
even be lifted off the ground
that's the Smarty thing to do the
tornado of course passes over without
one bit of debris touching them and
apparently keeping the wind breeze to a
minimum as they can keep their eyes open
to witness the center
Wow it's so implausible
and once again after it passes over them
the mighty f5 twister decides to vanish
into thin air Ardeth kitchen next time
Paxton next time I still want a divorce
so after giving the finger to the finger
of God and surviving what no other
person in the history of mankind has
ever survived what do our main
characters do argue you got us cut
analysis little that Danna I do yeah we
got to generate models out of all this
dead and I need to run the lab you're
doing the analysis I'm running the lab
you're prepping the lab oh I don't think
so
haha shut up shut up you're an idiot
you're bitch you're annoying and you're
god-awful movie why was this movie such
a big hit because of the effect nothing
else because when you really look at
this ass fest of a movie you see nothing
but what a Spence always produce crap
crap crap
it's so very weakly bad that even scared
the Burger King away and he's usually
the ones giving other people away come
on come on dee Jane come out from under
the bed he's crying now
come on Philip Seymour Hoffman isn't
here anymore no he's gone Oh pull si I'm
gonna stop I remember it so you know
handle there oh come on get you some
McDonald's ah sorry
you